Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. And now I'm in the world alone Upon the wide, wide sea
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、享受无广告收听、提前解锁系列内容并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听加更节目、提前解锁内容、享受无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。现在我独自留在这个世界上，在大海茫茫之中
But why should I for others groan When none will sigh for me? Perchance my dog will whine in vain Till fed by stranger hands But long ere I come back again He'd tear me where he stands dominic sandbrook anyone who has to leave behind pets when they go on holiday will be familiar with that sentiment the anxiety of coming back from your fortnight abroad to find that your dog
为什么我要为别人叹息，而没有人为我叹息呢？也许我的狗会白白呜咽，直到被陌生人的手喂养，但在我回来之前很久，它就会把我撕碎。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，任何在度假时不得不留下宠物的人都会对这种情感感到熟悉，那种在国外度过两周后回来发现自己的狗
wants to tear you to pieces uh that was in fact, Lord Byron writing in the character of Childe Harold about, well, let's call it a holiday, a trip abroad that he made in 1809. And we'll come back to Byron. But we're looking at the theme of holidays because we're in the middle of August. This is absolutely the holiday season. People are going abroad, they're braving, you know, terrible flights, all that kind of stuff to get abroad. And we thought it would be fun to look at the history of the holiday, of people going away, going on trips, having breaks. And I guess in a sense, if we're looking at the prehistory of it, what Byron is doing, so he leaves England, he heads off for two years going around the Mediterranean.
想把你撕成碎片的焦虑。呃，事实上那是拜伦勋爵以恰尔德·哈罗德的角色写的，关于——嗯，我们称之为假期吧——他在1809年的一次出国旅行。我们会回到拜伦的话题上来。但我们正在探讨假期的主题，因为我们正处于八月中旬。这绝对是度假季节。人们出国，你知道的，勇敢地面对糟糕的航班，以及诸如此类的事情去国外。我们觉得回顾历史上的假期、人们外出旅游、度假会很有趣。我想从某种意义上说，如果我们回顾它的前身，拜伦在做什么呢？他离开英格兰，前往地中海游历两年。
That's very much what aristocrats are doing throughout the late 17th through the 18th century, aren't they? So it's called the Grand Tour. And I know that you've been doing a lot of swatting on this. Would you say that the Grand Tour is the precursor of what we know today as holidays? Yes, I probably would actually, Tom. Hello, everybody.
这非常符合17世纪末到整个18世纪贵族们的做法，不是吗？所以这被称为“壮游”（Grand Tour）。我知道你在这方面下了很多功夫。你会说“壮游”是我们今天所知的假期的前身吗？是的，我大概会这么认为，汤姆。大家好。
Yes, I think so. So we're going to talk later on in the week, aren't we? Or it's about Roman holidays, about their sort of antecedents to holidays. But I think obviously most people in human history never went on holiday. I mean, they were just working all the time, sort of tilling the fields or later on working in the factories or whatever they were doing. So holidays are kind of connected with the idea of leisure.
是的，我也这么认为。所以我们将在本周晚些时候讨论，不是吗？或者关于罗马假期，关于假期的一些前身。但我认为，人类历史上显然大多数人从未度过假。我的意思是，他们只是不停地工作，在田里耕作，或者后来在工厂工作，无论他们在做什么。所以假期在某种程度上与休闲的概念联系在一起。
And wealth. But they're also connected, aren't they, with the idea of self-improvement. So people, what books are you going to read on holiday? Are going to go swimming are you going to take up new sports are you going to see authentic local experiences you're going to broaden your mind by going to an art gallery all these kinds of things sightseeing exactly i mean these have always been part of the sort of the holiday ethic i suppose and um britain i think particularly has a i mean britain is a pioneer of holidays, of sort of travel, because, of course, the British are tremendous travellers in the 18th and 19th centuries. But also, do you think that's because we're an island? I think it's partly that.
还有财富。但它们也与自我提升的概念密不可分，不是吗？所以人们，你在假期打算读什么书？你要去游泳吗？你要开始新的运动吗？你要去寻找真实的当地体验吗？你要去美术馆开阔眼界吗？所有这些事情，观光游览，完全是这样——我的意思是，这些一直是度假伦理的一部分，我想，嗯——英国我认为尤其有一个——我的意思是英国是假期和旅行的先驱，因为当然，英国人在18和19世纪是非常了不起的旅行者。但你认为这也是因为我们是一个岛国吗？我想部分原因是这个。
And I think it's also the British abroad, because it's also slightly connected with empire and exploration and so on. But the British abroad is a perennially comic subject isn't it because there's so much we basically travel with bags stuffed with prejudices snobberies normally about one another well not exclusively i mean you know also know about other people too obviously a lot of sneering about foreigners as well yeah germans in particular i guess um but yeah i think it's a tremendous subject there's lots of lots of fun to be had and i think the grand tour is a great place to kick off because that's if anyone who's did you ever go inter-railing tom when you were a youngster yeah where did you go italy went pretty much everywhere yeah i went to italy yeah germany france spain everywhere well there you go i mean
我想这也与英国人在海外有关，因为它也稍微与帝国和探险等等联系在一起。但英国人在海外是一个长盛不衰的滑稽主题，不是吗？因为我们旅行时总是塞满了各种偏见和势利眼，通常是针对彼此的——好吧，也不完全是，我的意思是，你知道的，显然也了解其他人，对外国人也有很多冷嘲热讽，对吧？尤其是德国人，我猜，嗯——但是是的，我认为这是一个极好的主题，有很多乐趣可以挖掘，我认为“壮游”是一个绝佳的切入点，因为那是——如果有谁——汤姆，你年轻时去过欧洲火车通票（inter-railing）旅行吗？是的，你去过哪里？意大利，几乎到处都去了，是的。我去过意大利，是的，德国、法国、西班牙，到处都去过。好吧，你看，我的意思是
that basically is the grand tour isn't it because you set off from england um you know people who go interrailing or backpacking now from all over the world they go normally between the ages of about 18 and 25 and they go to broaden their minds to have fun they go with the promise of kind of often the promise of sex is part of it and and those things were all true the grand tour and france and italy which were obviously the two countries that were most visited by British aristocrats going on the Grand Tour, I think that they're still kind of the epicentre of the global tourism business, aren't they? I think they're the most visited. I think they are. I think they are the most visited. France, Italy and Spain. Yeah, absolutely.
这基本上就是壮游，不是吗？因为你从英格兰出发，嗯——现在世界各地进行欧洲火车通票旅行或背包旅行的人，他们通常在18岁到25岁之间，他们为了开阔眼界、为了寻找乐趣而出发，他们带着对性的承诺——通常性也是其中的一部分——出发，所有这些在壮游中都是真的。法国和意大利，显然是英国贵族进行壮游时访问最多的两个国家，我认为它们仍然是全球旅游业的中心，不是吗？我认为它们是访问量最大的。我想是的。我认为它们确实是访问量最大的。法国、意大利和西班牙。是的，完全正确。
But in the 18th century, why is it distinctively British aristocrats who are doing this? Is it because they're stuck on an island? Is it because the 18th century, the British are kind of having a quantum leap in terms of wealth? So are they just richer than everyone else? What's going on? There's a really easy answer to that, Tom, which is that it isn't actually the British who are exclusively doing this. We often think it is because it's the British who have actually written about this more than anybody else.
但在18世纪，为什么进行这项活动的明显是英国贵族呢？是因为他们被困在岛上吗？是因为在18世纪，英国人在财富方面实现了一次质的飞跃吗？所以他们只是比其他人更富有？到底是怎么回事？汤姆，有一个非常简单的答案，那就是实际上并不只有英国人在做这件事。我们经常认为只有英国人，是因为英国人比其他任何人都写下了更多关于这方面的文字。
But historians are starting to notice that actually there were tons of Germans, there were tons of Swedes, tons of Scandinavians going on these sort of odysseys. But it's the British who seem to have been most... I think because the British came back, and they brought all
但历史学家开始注意到，实际上有大量的德国人，大量的瑞典人，大量的斯堪的纳维亚人也进行了这种奥德赛式的旅行。但似乎是英国人最……我想是因为英国人回来了，他们带回了所有
the... as we'll discover, they brought all the art and the sculptures they brought the aesthetic back with them so they built their country houses and kind of palladian styles they picked up in you know in in florence or sort of rome or whatever um and the british just seemed to have they just they just seemed to have become much more fixated than anybody else i think perhaps partly because of the island, because we were, and also because Britain was kind of defining itself against the continent in the 18th century, wasn't it? The age of kind of Linda Colley's Britain. Well, I suppose, but there is also the idea
——正如我们将要发现的，他们带回了所有的艺术品和雕塑，他们把这种美学带了回来，所以他们在帕拉第奥风格（Palladian）中建造了他们的乡村庄园，这些风格是他们在佛罗伦萨或罗马等地领略到的，嗯，英国人似乎——他们只是似乎比其他人更加痴迷，我想也许部分是因为岛屿的原因，因为我们是，而且还因为在18世纪英国正试图划清与欧洲大陆的界限，不是吗？琳达·科利（Linda Colley）笔下的英国时代。好吧，我想是的，但这也存在着一种
of a kind of common European civilization, isn't there? I mean, for instance. Yeah, there is. A common inheritance from the classical inheritance. But also French. So you would usually go to Paris first, mug up on French. Because French was the English of the 18th century. It was the lingua franca.
共同的欧洲文明的概念，不是吗？我的意思是，比如。是的，确实有。对古典传统的共同继承。还有法语。所以你通常会先去巴黎，恶补法语。因为法语是18世纪的英语。它是通用语（lingua franca）。
You couldn't really get around it. That's right. Well, let's dig back a bit to the origins of it. So, I mean, as you will know far better than me, Tom, people had been going to Rome for centuries. So Alfred the Grey went to Rome, didn't he? When he was a little boy. So going to Rome on these sort of pilgrimages, I suppose. Well, they're absolutely pilgrimages.
你真的无法绕过它。没错。好吧，让我们回溯一点它的起源。所以，正如你比我更清楚的那样，汤姆，几个世纪以来人们一直在去罗马。所以阿尔弗雷德大帝曾去过罗马，不是吗？当他还是个小男孩的时候。所以去罗马进行这种朝圣之旅，我想。好吧，它们绝对是朝圣之旅。
I mean, that is the thing. They have kind of religion absolutely at their heart. People aren't doing that in the mid-16th century, are they? I mean, Henry VIII has no plans to go on a pilgrimage to Rome in 1540. Well, so obviously it's a Catholic thing, as anyone who's read The Canterbury Tales will know. It's a Catholic thing, but it provides lots and lots of scope for fun along the way. So go on a pilgrimage, you're likely to hear all kinds of people telling you tales in rhyming couplets great fun right nice but with the reformation obviously that falls into abeyance but it's interesting so milton goes on a foreign trip he goes to italy he goes and sees galileo
我的意思是，这就是重点。它们的核心完全是宗教。16世纪中期的人们可不这么做，不是吗？我的意思是，亨利八世在1540年可没有计划去罗马朝圣。好吧，所以这显然是一件天主教的事情，正如读过《坎特伯雷故事集》的人所知。这是一件天主教的事情，但它沿途也为人们提供了大量寻欢作乐的机会。所以去朝圣，你很可能会听到各种各样的人用押韵的双行体给你讲故事，这很有趣，对吧？不错。但随着宗教改革，这显然就废止了。不过这很有趣，弥尔顿去进行了一次国外旅行，他去了意大利，去拜访了伽利略
um he goes and sees the sites but there's a kind of incredible sense of of earnestness i think about about that milton is going because he his ambition is to become the english virgil and so therefore he needs he feels he needs to have seen italy before he can possibly hope to achieve that um that's true that's what he'd tell his accountant i think that's true lots of the grand tourists the original grand tourists so the very early ones. So later on, you get to the sex and the boardiness, and I'm sure we're going to have lots of that to come because I know you've got loads of boardiness up your sleeve some.
嗯，他去参观了名胜古迹，但我觉得其中有一种令人难以置信的严肃感，弥尔顿去那里是因为他的雄心壮志是成为英国的维吉尔，因此他觉得在希望实现这一目标之前，他需要先去看看意大利——这是真的，这就是他会告诉他的会计的，我想这是真的。许多壮游者，最初的壮游者——也就是最早的那批人。所以后来，你就会接触到性和放荡，我确信我们接下来会有很多这样的内容，因为我知道你脑子里藏着大量放荡的故事，汤姆。
But supposedly the first, as far as I can discover, the man who really sort of institutionalized the grand tourist, somebody called Thomas Howard, Earl of Arundel. So this is 1613, 1614. It's the reign of- of he's a catholic would that be yes yes the howard family exactly and it may be significant actually yes because he means he's not he doesn't have sort of anti-romish baggage and he goes he takes his wife he takes his children he goes all the way through italy and he goes to naples he and he goes with inigo jones the great architect the great sort of designer um so inigo jones at that point is best known for his masks i know you love a court mask tom love a court mask yeah so inigo jones
但据我所能查到的，据我所知的第一位真正将壮游制度化的人，是一个叫托马斯·霍华德（Thomas Howard），阿伦德尔伯爵（Earl of Arundel）的人。所以这是1613年、1614年。正是——他是天主教徒，对吗？是的，是的，霍华德家族，完全正确。这可能意义重大，是的，因为这意味着他没有反罗马的包袱。他去了，他带着他的妻子，他带着他的孩子，他一路穿过意大利，他去了那不勒斯，他和伊尼戈·琼斯（Inigo Jones）一起去——伟大的建筑师，伟大的设计师，嗯——所以伊尼戈·琼斯在那个时候最出名的是他的假面舞会（masque），我知道你喜欢宫廷假面舞会，汤姆。喜欢宫廷假面舞会，是的。所以伊尼戈·琼斯
goes as his guide and that sort of idea that you go with a guide who's a tutor at the same time who's more sort of plugged into the art and the architecture. Yeah. So it's like a kind of guest lecturer on a cruise. Precisely. That's exactly what it is. So Arendt goes and does this and he comes back. He has tons of art. I mean, he buys things by Leonardo and Raphael and stuff. He's really into this.
作为他的向导同行，这种你和一个兼任导师的向导一起旅行的想法，这个向导对艺术和建筑更加精通。是的。所以这有点像游轮上的客座讲座。正是如此。这完全就是那么回事。所以阿伦德尔去了，做了这些，然后他回来了。他有大量的艺术品。我的意思是，他买了一些达芬奇、拉斐尔等人的作品。他真的很迷恋这个。
Now, this is the 1610. So it's very early on to be doing all this. Yeah. But again, I mean, Dominic, this is also kind of setting a trend, isn't it? Because to this day, if you go abroad, you come back with, with tat. Uh, I mean, obviously Leonardo isn't tat, but, um, you know, you'll come back with an Eiffel tat model of the Eiffel tower or something or whatever. Exactly. Holidaying and collecting have always gone hand in hand. So obviously people don't do it during the 30 Years' War or the English Civil Wars, British Civil Wars so much. I mean, there are obstacles.
现在，这是1610年代。所以做这一切的时间非常早。是的。但话说回来，多米尼克，这也是在开创一种趋势，不是吗？因为直到今天，如果你出国，你回来时也会带一些小纪念品（tat）。嗯，当然达芬奇不是小纪念品，但是，嗯，你知道的，你会带回一个埃菲尔铁塔的小模型或其他什么东西回来。完全是这样。度假和收集纪念品总是手挽手相伴的。所以显然在三十年战争或英国内战、英国内战期间，人们并没有这样做。我的意思是，有很多阻碍。
But after the end of the 30 Years' War, 1648, and then the Restoration, 1660, it really starts up again. We have the first mention of the phrase, the Grand Tour, so that's in 1670. And again, actually interestingly, going back to your point about Catholicism, it's by a Catholic priest who is abroad. He's an expatriate. He's called Richard Lascelles.
但在三十年战争结束后，即1648年，然后是王政复辟（Restoration），即1660年，它真正重新开始了。我们有了关于“壮游”这一词组的最早记载，那是在1670年。同样，有趣的是，回到你关于天主教的观点，这是一个在国外的天主教神父提出的。他是一个侨民。他叫理查德·拉塞尔斯（Richard Lascelles）。
He writes a book called The Village of Italy, and he calls this the Grand Tour, and the name kind of catches on. And indeed, in that book, you know, it's your point about the earnestness at the beginning. It doesn't sound much like holiday fun, because Laszlo says the point of being of travel, he says there are four reasons to do it. They are intellectual, social, political, and ethical. Now, obviously, you have all those things still today, don't you? Plus la change. Yeah, plus la change. you have all those things still today don't you intellectual yeah i mean he doesn't this sort of
他写了一本名为《意大利之旅》（The Village of Italy）的书，他把这称为“壮游”，这个名字不知怎么就流行起来了。事实上，在那本书里，你知道的，这呼应了你关于一开始那种严肃性的观点。这听起来一点也不像假期那么好玩，因为拉塞尔斯说旅行的意义在于，他说有四个理由去做这件事。它们是：智力、社交、政治和道德。现在，显然你今天仍然拥有所有这些东西，不是吗？一切皆变，一切依旧（Plus la change）。是的，一切皆变，一切依旧。你今天仍然拥有所有这些东西，不是吗？智力，是的，我的意思是，他没有——这种
paddle boarding and um dancing in nightclubs do not feature in lasso's but then after 1660 it becomes the thing so you're it's generally aristocrats isn't it who do it you need a lot of money um and you need connections you need you need a kind of wherewithal. That's sort of what I always think of as that sort of James Bond ability to walk into the hotel and say, you know, presidential suite. Yeah, my usual, your usual, Mr. Bond. Basically, you need to be able to walk in in full confidence that nobody will say we're fully booked. Well, there's that very rather sad comment by Dr. Johnson, who, of course, was not a milord and so therefore couldn't afford to go on a grand tour. That a man who has not been in Italy is always conscious of an inferiority from his not having seen what it is expected a man should see. Which is, I guess, speaking for, you know, whole classes of people who would love to go to Italy,
桨板冲浪和夜总会跳舞并没有出现在拉塞尔斯的书中，但1660年后它成为了潮流。所以你——通常是贵族在做这件事，不是吗？你需要大量的资金，嗯，你需要人脉，你需要一种经济实力。这差不多就是我所认为的那种詹姆斯·邦德式的能力，能够走进酒店并说：“你知道的，总统套房。”“是的，老规矩，邦德先生。”基本上，你需要能够充满信心地走进去，确信没有人会说“我们已经客满了”。好吧，约翰逊博士有一句相当悲伤的评论，他当然不是勋爵，因此负担不起去进行壮游的费用：一个没有去过意大利的人，总是会因为没有见过人们期望一个男人见过的事物而感到一种自卑感。我想这代表了（你知道的）
but for whom it's just kind of an impossible dream? Well, you have to be able to. So you have to have had some grounding. You have to have had an education, a classical education, so Greek and Latin, because you need to know what you're going to see. You need to be able to afford the tutor. So the tutors were called bear leaders, or they're called cicerones. So that's Cicero, Tom.
整个阶层的人，他们很想去意大利，但对他们来说这只是一种不可能实现的梦想？嗯，你必须具备资格。所以你必须有一些基础。你必须接受过教育，古典教育，比如希腊语和拉丁语，因为你需要知道你要去看什么。你需要负担得起导师的费用。所以这些导师被称为“熊领主”（bear leaders），或者被称为西塞罗导游（cicerones）。所以那是西塞罗，汤姆。
It's from the idea of... So the tutor is a sort of Ciceronian figure who will talk to you about... What could be more fun than going on holiday with Cicero? Because that's awful. It sounds absolutely awful. No, it'd be great. Cicero is a great wit.
这个概念来自于……所以导师是一个类似西塞罗的人物，他会跟你谈论——还有什么比和西塞罗一起度假更有趣的呢？因为那太糟糕了。听起来绝对糟糕透顶。不，那会很棒。西塞罗是一个极具风趣的人。
Someone who would just talk to you about rhetoric. No, you wouldn't. All on your holiday. But it's also, the idea that it's an individual experience, it's just like interrailing in this regard. Because basically at every stop, you're surrounded by other grand tourists. You know, there are particular hotels and taverns
一个只会跟你谈论修辞学的人。不，你不会的。全在你的假期里。但这也是，这是一种个人体验的想法，在这方面它就像欧洲火车通票旅行。因为基本上在每一站，你都被其他壮游者包围着。你知道的，有特定的酒店和小酒馆，
and it's just full of like, my Lord of Bath. Yeah. Fancy meeting you here. It's full of hooray Henrys. Let of like my Lord of Bath. Yeah. Fancy meeting you here. It's full of Hooray Henrys. Let us go out on the town. Yeah. Do you want to go and look at some Palladian architecture?
到处都是像巴斯勋爵这样的人。是的。真巧在这里遇到你。到处都是那些趾高气扬的阔少爷（Hrorry Henrys）。到处都是像巴斯勋爵这样的人。是的。真巧在这里遇到你。到处都是那些趾高气扬的阔少爷。让我们去城里狂欢吧。是的。你想去看看帕拉第奥式建筑吗？
No, I want to go and get hammered. Woof, woof. I think there's an awful amount of that. I think there's... Yeah. So basically, do you want me to tell you about the route? Shall I tell you about the route?
不，我想去喝个酩酊大醉。汪，汪。我认为有相当大一部分人是这样的。我认为有——是的。所以基本上，你想让我给你讲讲路线吗？我应该给你讲讲路线吗？
Would you like to tell me about the route? Yeah. Yeah. Tell me about the route. You set off, you cross the channel, you go to Calais-aux- or lave and then you go to um paris and there you are instructed in dancing fencing riding all these kinds of things so you're by french dancing masters by french dancing masters so you get a bit of polish then from there you go this may surprise some
你想给我讲讲路线吗？对。对。跟我讲讲路线。你出发，穿过海峡，你去加来或勒阿弗尔，然后你去——嗯——巴黎，在那里你接受舞蹈、击剑、骑马等各种事情的培训——所以是由法国舞蹈大师指导的——由法国舞蹈大师指导的，这样你就沾染了一点优雅。然后从那里你去——这可能会让一些
people you go to switzerland so switzerland which is not a great inter-ailing place today, it was a massive... It's too expensive, isn't it? It is too expensive, but it was not, clearly, in the 18th century. So you'd go to Geneva or you'd go to Lausanne. And the appeal of that is also because Switzerland, of course, is very Protestant. So the thinking was that this would sort of inoculate you
人感到惊讶——你去瑞士。所以瑞士，今天可不是一个进行欧洲火车通票旅行的好地方，它是一个巨大的——太贵了，对吧？确实太贵了，但显然在18世纪并非如此。所以你会去日内瓦或洛桑。这样做的吸引力还在于，瑞士当然是一个非常新教的国家。所以当时的观点是，这可以在以后
against excessive Catholicism later on. So Gibbon, Edward Gibbon, the great historian, he was sent to Lausanne because of his papist tendencies when he was a young man. His family thought he was becoming dangerously Romish, and so they forced him to go to Switzerland, where the sort of thin gruel and high peaks would encourage more sound views on religion.
帮你“接种疫苗”，防止你过度沉迷于天主教。所以吉本，爱德华·吉本，伟大的历史学家，他年轻时因为有天主教倾向而被送到了洛桑。他的家人认为他变得危险地具有罗马天主教倾向，因此他们强迫他去瑞士，那里单调乏味的粗茶淡饭和崇山峻岭将促使他形成更健全的宗教观点。
So then from there you go over the Alps. Now, obviously, going over the Alps to us is dead easy. To them is very difficult. So you, oh, by the way, you'll have bought a coach in Paris. So this is a bit like people going on road trips and buying a car and then selling it at the end. You'll have bought this carriage, and you'll also probably have a load of servants
然后从那里你翻越阿尔卑斯山。现在，显然，对我们来说翻越阿尔卑斯山易如反掌。对他们来说却非常困难。所以你——哦，顺便说一句，你会在巴黎买一辆马车。所以这有点像人们去自驾游然后买辆车最后再把它卖掉。你会买下这辆马车，而且你可能还会带上一大批仆人
who will be carrying your stuff. But but when you go over the alps don't the servants carry actually carry you physically if you're lucky they will dismantle the carriage and take its pieces and carry it over the alps but if you're if you're rich really rich the servants will carry you over the house as well so that's business class that is that is business well that's business class. That is business. Well, that's first class, I think. So from there, you go to Turin or you go to Milan. You might go to Florence. And you're now looking at art. Do you go to Venice?
来帮你搬运行李。但是——但是当你翻越阿尔卑斯山时，仆人们难道不是真的用身体抬着你吗？如果你幸运的话，他们会把马车拆成零件，然后把零件扛过阿尔卑斯山；但如果你很富有——真的非常富有，仆人们也会把你们抬过山。所以那是商务舱，那是——那是商务舱。那是商务。好吧，那是头等舱，我想。所以从那里，你去都灵或米兰。你可能会去佛罗伦萨。你现在开始看艺术品了。你会去威尼斯吗？
You go to Venice a bit later, actually. You go to... So off to Florence, you go to Padua, you go to Bologna, and you go to Venice. So Venice is obviously one of the great sort of destinations, one of the big high points, but the real high point is Rome. I mean, Rome is the place you are sort of setting out to see. And when you get to Rome, Rome is full of the infrastructure. You know, just like interrailing and backpacking, you rely on a tourist infrastructure. Rome has all the, you know, it has sort of taverns, it has hotels. It has painters who will paint picturesque scenes for you. It has entrepreneurs who will sell you tat,
你其实要晚一点才去威尼斯。你去——所以离开佛罗伦萨后，你去帕多瓦，你去博洛尼亚，然后你去威尼斯。所以威尼斯显然是那些伟大的目的地之一，是高潮之一，但真正的最高潮是罗马。我的意思是，罗马才是你出发要去看的地方。当你到达罗马时，罗马到处都是基础设施。你知道的，就像欧洲火车通票旅行和背包旅行一样，你依赖于旅游基础设施。罗马拥有所有——你知道的，它有小酒馆，有酒店。它有会为你绘制风景如画的画作的画家。它有会向你兜售小纪念品的企业家，
so who have huge ranges of sort of supposedly antique busts and stuff. And there will be people who will act as middlemen and all that kind of thing. And then from there, you will go to Naples. And Naples, as you will know, Tom know you'll get to see herculaneum and pompeii so the excavations and herculaneum started in 1738 in pompeii in 1748 so you know you're basically seeing live archaeology and you're and if you're if you're smart you're carrying off loads you're like grabbing the stuff and putting it into your, getting your servants.
他们拥有大量所谓的古董半身像之类的东西。还会有充当中间人的各种角色等等。然后从那里，你会去那不勒斯。正如你所知，汤姆，你会去参观赫库兰尼姆和庞贝——所以赫库兰尼姆的发掘始于1738年，庞贝始于1748年——所以，你知道的，你基本上是在看现场考古，如果你——如果你聪明的话，你会大肆搜刮，你会像抢东西一样把它们塞进你的——让你的仆人。
You're elganing. Exactly. Yeah. That's exactly what you're doing. I'm right, aren't I, that Naples, I mean, Naples at this point is what? Almost as large, I mean, maybe larger than London and Paris. I mean, it's. Yeah, it's about the third largest city in Europe.
你在大肆掠夺（elganing）。完全正确。是的。这正是你一直在做的事。我没说错吧，那不勒斯——在那时的那不勒斯是什么？几乎和伦敦、巴黎一样大，甚至可能比它们还大。我的意思是——是的，它是欧洲第三大城市。
And a great kind of mecca in its own right. I mean, it's got opera houses. It's got its own court. It's tremendously fashionable. Yeah, so Naples has got everything. So Naples doesn't just have, I mean, it does have the opera house and it does have the sort of the patina of cosmopolitanism and sort of high culture, but it also has the picturesque.
它本身就是一个伟大的麦加圣地。我的意思是，它有歌剧院。它有自己的宫廷。它极其时尚。是的，所以那不勒斯拥有一切。所以那不勒斯不仅有——我的意思是，它确实有歌剧院，确实有那种大都会的气息和高级文化的韵味，但它也有风景如画的自然风光。
So as you're getting later on in the 18th century, and sort of romanticism is beginning to... So you're getting Vesuvius, aren't you? To loom. Vesuvius, yeah. So there's a story about a woman called hester lynch piozzi she went to naples in 1789 she said to her she pointed at the suvius and she said to a friar is that the famous volcano and this friar said yes that is our mountain which throws up money for us by calling foreigners to see the
所以随着18世纪进入后期，浪漫主义开始——所以你会看到维苏威火山，对吧？去卢姆。维苏威火山，是的。所以有一个关于一个叫海斯特·林奇·皮奥齐（Hester Lynch Piozzi）的女人的故事，她在1789年去了那不勒斯，她对——她指着维苏威火山对一个修士说，那是那座著名的火山吗？这个修士说：“是的，那是我们的山，它通过召唤外国人来看如此令人惊叹的奇观所带来的非凡影响，为我们吐出了金钱。”所以显然，你知道的，对于意大利人来说，这一切都很棒——所有这些人，是的，所有这些带着成吨金钱、由仆人抬着的哈里王子式的人物，嗯——但是显然，除了那种——我知道你可能觉得艺术方面的东西非常无聊，汤姆，所以我把它保持在最低限度——我没有，我没有，我没有，但你接着说。所以他们把美学带了回来——帕拉第奥主义（Palladianism）、新古典主义艺术和建筑——所以他们在这种风格中建造了他们的乡村庄园，比如斯托海德（Stourhead），你去过斯托海德吗？是的，斯托海德，完全正确，或者斯托庄园（Stowe），在那里他们淹没了一个村庄，在它上面修建了一个湖，并在湖周围建造了古典风格的庙宇——
extraordinary effects of so surprising a phenomenon so obviously you know for the italians this is all great that all these people yeah all these sort of prince harryish figures atelier with being carried by servants with tons of money um but obviously as well as the sort of so i know you find the art stuff very potentially very boring tom so i'll keep this to a minimum i don't i no i don't i don't but go on so they bring back the aesthetic so of kind of palladianism of neo-classical art and architecture so they do all their country houses in this style so stourhead you ever been to stourhead yes stourhead exactly or stow where they drowned a village um put a lake over it and built kind of classical temples around it
这太棒了，是的，确实不错。如果我是一个贵族勋爵，这正是我会做的事——我的意思是，建立一个村庄，在上面修建一个湖，并在湖周围建造了古典风格的庙宇。这太棒了。是的，确实不错。如果我是一个贵族勋爵，这正是我会做的事。我的意思是，斯托庄园（Stowe House）在——那是在哪里？白金汉宫郡，我想？我的意思是，那绝对是非常壮观。又一个国民信托（National Trust）的房子。同样，采用了这种意大利新古典主义风格，
it's fantastic yeah it is good if i was a mere lord that's exactly what i would have done i mean Found a village, put a lake over it, and built kind of classical temples around it. It's fantastic. Yeah, it is good. If I was a mere lord, that's exactly what I would have done. I mean, Stowe House in, where is that? Buckinghamshire, I suppose? I mean, that is absolutely spectacular. Another National Trust house. Again, done in this sort of Italianate neoclassical style,
显然受到了壮游的启发，里面塞满了半身像和雕像等等。这些东西是对他们在国外所见事物的刻意模仿。我的意思是，通常那些塞满房间的东西都是字面意义上被掠夺来的。所以有一个叫理查德·博伊尔（Richard Boyle），第三代伯灵顿伯爵（3rd Earl of Burlington）的家伙。他在1714年到1719年之间进行了旅行。所以这些通常是历时多年的旅行。你知道的，你不仅仅是去一个月就回来的。你可能会离开两三年。
clearly informed by the Grand Tour with all the busts and the statues and so on. And these things are deliberate imitations of what people have seen abroad. I mean, often the things that they're stuffed with have literally been taken. So there's a bloke called Richard Boyle, 3rd Earl of Burlington. He went on tours between 1714 and 1719. So these are often multi-year. You know, you don't just go there and back in a month. You could be away for two or three years.
他带回了——你知道他带回了多少箱大理石、画作和花瓶吗？40箱？868箱。好吧，我远没有达到那个数字。那可真是大丰收，不是吗？那真的是大丰收。那是一个非常非常令人印象深刻的收获。
And he brings back, do you know how many crates of marbles and paintings and vases he brings back with him? 40. 868. Okay, I didn't remotely get near that. That is a haul, isn't it? That really is a haul. That is a very, very impressive haul.
他拿这些东西做了什么？他把它们放进他的房子里，或者说他的房子足够大吗？嗯，一定是这样吧。或者也许建了一个附属建筑？我猜他有多处房产，一栋城市住宅和一栋乡村庄园。是的，我猜是的。嗯——我的意思是，我很想去参加壮游。然而，有一件事我绝对不会做，那就是把外国的时尚带回国，这是我们在关于2020年欧洲杯的英意关系的播客中讨论过的话题，所以那些马卡罗尼（macaronis）——那些梳着这种夸张的发型、穿着高跟鞋的人，人们把意大利或法国化的时尚带回国内，随着世纪的推移，他们从各种讽刺版画和
What did he do with it? Did he put in his house kind of or was his house big enough well it must have been yeah or maybe build an annex i would assume he had multiple a townhouse and a country house yes i guess yeah um i mean i would love to have gone on the grand talk the one thing i would not have done however is to bring back the foreign fashions which is something that we talked about in our podcast about anglo-italian relations for euro 2020 so the the macaronis people with this sort of massive hair and with high heels and so people bringing back um italian it or sort of frenchified fashions and they as the century wears on they get more and more grief from the kind of satirical prints and
新闻纸等渠道受到了越来越多的指责，是的，因为他们的假发越来越高耸挺拔，不是吗，还有诸如此类的事情——我能讲讲我最喜欢的进行过壮游的家伙吗？他就是詹姆斯·博斯韦尔（James Boswell）。他既是一个了不起的家伙，也是一个糟糕的家伙，不是吗，博斯韦尔？是的，嗯——他关于壮游的经历是一段壮丽的经历，所以他。
new sheets and things yeah because they're kind of increasingly steeplingly high wigs don't they and all that um can i just tell you my favorite guy who went on a grand tour is james boswell he's both a splendid fellow and a terrible fellow isn't he boswell yes um his his experience of the grand tour is is a magnificent one so he. So he's the son of a Scottish laird. He's come down to London. He's made friends with Dr. Johnson. And he's going off on what will become a two-year trip around Europe. And there's this kind of very moving description of him. Dr. Johnson has come down to bid him farewell. And he johnson standing on the pier and then kind of rolling off with this kind of rolling gate and um off boswell goes to the netherlands full of vows
所以他是一个苏格兰乡绅的儿子。他来到了伦敦。他与约翰逊博士交了朋友。他将开始一段长达两年的欧洲之旅。这里有一个关于他非常感人的描述。约翰逊博士来为他送行。他——约翰逊站在码头上，然后以那种摇晃的步伐蹒跚离开，博斯韦尔就出发去了荷兰，满怀誓言——
you know he's going to be good he's going to be moral he's going to be everything johnson would want and immediately it's kind of woof woof he's straight off he's uh you know i mean he just can't keep it in but he he keeps getting attacked by sort of, he's got to be improving. So he'll have a kind of week of going around all the brothels and then he'll say, no, I've got to stop this. I've got to improve myself. And so he is in Germany and he gets to Berlin and he thinks, do you know what I'd really like to do? And this is actually quite a theme of the great tour. You don't just want to go and see sights. You want to go and see famous people. And so Boswell thinks I'm going to go and see sights. You want to go and see famous people.
你知道的，他要做好人，他要保持道德，他要成为约翰逊期望的一切，而立刻——这就好像“汪，汪”，他马上就——你知道的，我的意思是，他就是克制不住自己——但他不断地受到攻击——你知道的，他必须提升自己。所以他会有一周的时间流连于各大妓院，然后他说：“不，我必须停止这一切。我必须提升自己。”所以他在德国，他到了柏林，他想：“你知道我真正想做的是什么吗？这其实是壮游的一个主要主题。你不仅仅想去观光。你想去拜访名人。”所以博斯韦尔想——你想去拜访名人。
And so Boswell thinks, I'm going to go and see the two most famous people in Europe, Rousseau and Voltaire. And so he also, from Germany, goes to Switzerland. So you were saying about how Switzerland is a regular stop off. And he goes to Motier near Neuchatel in switzerland where rousseau is staying and he writes this letter to rousseau i am a scots gentleman of ancient family now you know my rank i am 24 years old now you know my age 16 months ago i left great britain a completely insular being did he have leon neeson's voice knowing hardly a word of french i have been in holland and in germany but not yet in france
所以博斯韦尔想：“我要去见欧洲最著名的两个人，卢梭和伏尔泰。”于是他也从德国出发去瑞士。所以你刚才说瑞士是一个固定的中转站。他去了瑞士纳沙泰尔附近的莫捷（Motier），卢梭当时正住在那里，他给卢梭写了这样一封信：“我是个古老家族的苏格兰绅士，现在你知道我的阶级了；我24岁了，现在你知道我的年龄了；16个月前我离开大不列颠，成了一个彻头彻尾的岛民——”他当时用的是连姆·尼森（Liam Neeson）的嗓音吗？——“几乎不会说一句法语；我去过荷兰和德国，但还没去过法国。”
you will therefore excuse my handling of the language i am traveling with a genuine desire to improve myself i have come here in the hope of seeing you so that's exactly how he spoke dominic and he finishes off by by by saying i have a presentiment that a truly noble friendship will be born today. And Rousseau is kind of notoriously grumpy, but he says, fine, come along. So Boswell goes along and he asks Rousseau, you know, they have a chat. Boswell's very personable, very interested, very interesting person. Rousseau gets on quite well with him. Boswell ends up saying basically to Rousseau, will you become my mentor?
“因此，请原谅我对这门语言的笨拙运用。我带着真诚提升自我的愿望在旅行。我怀着希望能见到您的愿望来到这里。”多米尼克，他当时就是这么说话的，他最后说：“我有一种预感，今天将诞生一份真正崇高的友谊。”而卢梭以脾气暴躁闻名，但他说：“好吧，进来吧。”于是博斯韦尔进去了，他问卢梭——你知道的，他们聊了聊。博斯韦尔非常平易近人，非常感兴趣，是一个非常有趣的人。卢梭和他相处得相当融洽。博斯韦尔最终对卢梭说：“你愿意成为我的导师吗？”
Will you, I suppose, become, we know, will you become my bear leader? I can't think of two more different men. Yeah. And Rousseau basically says, no, I won't. I don't want to do this. And what's more, I'm in pain. I need a chamber pot. And so he rushes off to sit
你愿意——我想我们可以这么说——你愿意成为我的“熊领主”吗？我想不出比这更截然不同的两个人了。是的。而卢梭基本上说：“不，我不会。我不想这么做。而且，我很痛苦。我需要一个便盆。”于是他急忙跑去坐在
on the chamber pot and russo instead of getting the message follows him and continues to kind of ask him questions about liberty and all this kind of stuff oh god and russo's last words to him is be off so off. So at this point, Boswell has got the message. And so he does go and he goes off to see Voltaire, who is equally quite welcoming. And again, they have a kind of long chat. Voltaire obviously finds Boswell hilarious and kind of in the end tells him to bog off as well. So Boswell then goes off to Rome, does all the usual stuff. But then he goes to Corsica, which is in the middle of a kind of great romantic rebellion, revolution. And he hangs out with Pasquale Paoli, who is the great kind of romantic Corsican leader.
便盆上，而卢梭不仅没有领会他的意思，反而跟着他进去，继续问他关于自由之类的各种问题。天哪！而卢梭对他说出的最后的话是：“滚开！”所以此时，博斯韦尔已经明白了。于是他动身去见伏尔泰，伏尔泰同样相当热情。他们又进行了一场漫长的谈话。伏尔泰显然觉得博斯韦尔滑稽极了，最后也叫他滚蛋。于是博斯韦尔去了罗马，做了所有常规的事情。但接着他去了科西嘉岛，当时那里正处于一场伟大的浪漫叛乱和革命之中。他与帕斯夸莱·帕奥利（Pasquale Paoli）混在一起，后者是伟大的浪漫主义科西嘉领袖。
And that's been suggested to him by Rousseau. And so Boswell has a lovely time there kind of playing the romantic and this you know again this is an absolute theme that and we'll see it again with byron that you go off and you meet people in you know if you're if you're kind of doing the extreme grand tour you don't just want to stick to rome or naples you want to go off to remote mountainous locations and meet exotic people with extraordinary facial hair, that kind of thing. So Boswell then goes back through Europe and he has an affair with Rousseau's lover and housekeeper, Therese. That's poor, but maybe is that revenge for the way Rousseau treated him?
那是卢梭向他建议的。于是博斯韦尔在那里度过了一段美好的时光，扮演着浪漫主义者的角色——你知道，这绝对是一个主题，我们会在拜伦身上再次看到这一点——你出发去一些地方结识人们——如果你进行的是极端壮游，你不会只想局限于罗马或那不勒斯，你想去偏远的山区，结识那些面部毛发极其奇特、充满异国情调的人，诸如此类。于是博斯韦尔随后穿过欧洲返回，并与卢梭的情妇兼管家特蕾丝（Therese）发生了婚外情。太糟糕了，不过这难道不是对卢梭对待他的一种报复吗？
No, not at all. I think he clearly fancied Therese when he'd met her, when he'd been with Rousseau. And he'd been writing to Therese quite a lot. And Therese basically, I think, ends up feeling sorry for him. And they have an affair. And Boswell goes back home. He takes Therese with him. By this point, Rousseau is in London. And so he drops Therese off and never tells Rousseau that he's cheated on him. Wow. But the thing that I think really marks Boswell out as an archetype, and again, we'll see this in Byron, but we see it, you know,
不，完全不是。我想他显然在和卢梭在一起时就看上了特蕾丝。而且他给特蕾丝写了很多信。我想特蕾丝基本上最终对产生了同情。他们发生了婚外情。博斯韦尔回了家。他把特蕾丝也带上了。此时卢梭在伦敦。于是他把特蕾丝放下，却从未告诉卢梭他给戴了绿帽子。哇！但真正让博斯韦尔成为一个原型的特质——再次强调，我们会在拜伦身上看到这一点，但我们也看到，你知道的，
I speak for myself as someone who went to India on a year off, on a gap year, and came back kind of festooned in Indian fashion. Tom, I can't believe you were such a parody but boswell comes back with a full corsican outfit oh you didn't do that which of course nobody else has please tell me you didn't do that he is not dressing up as a macaroni he's dressing up as a corsican freedom fighter right and so whenever there's a ball he will turn up in this corsican freedom fighter outfit and to begin with it cuts a tremendous dash but after about three or four people are starting to snare and so boss will get this message and he packs it up and
我以一个在间隔年（gap year）去印度待了一年、回来时浑身挂满印度时尚饰品的人的身份现身说法，汤姆，我不敢相信你竟然是个活生生的滑稽模仿。但博斯韦尔回来时穿了一套完整的科西嘉传统服饰！哦，你没有那么做吧？请告诉我你没有那么做。他不是打扮成马卡罗尼（macaroni），他打扮成了一个科西嘉自由战士，对吧？所以每当有舞会时，他就会穿着这套科西嘉自由战士的衣服出现。一开始，这确实给人留下了深刻的印象，但大约经过三四次后，人们开始冷嘲热讽，于是博斯韦尔意识到了这一点，他把它收起来了，
puts it to one side that is very funny did you come back with indian garb from your time in india i'm not going to say i can see from your expression we that you did. I think we should go to a break here. We should do. But Tom, did you not go and, did you not seek out famous people when you weren't travelling? No, I didn't do that. See, I did. My friend Simon and I sought out the secretary of the Bulgarian football union, Boncho Todorov.
放在了一边。这太好笑了。你从印度回来时带回印度服饰了吗？我不会说的。我从你的表情看出——你们确实带了。我想我们应该在这里休息一下。我们应该这么做。但是，汤姆，你在旅行时难道没有去寻找名人吗？不，我没有这么做。你看，我去了。我的朋友西蒙和我去寻找保加利亚足协秘书长邦乔·托多罗夫（Boncho Todorov）。
Did you? When we were in Sofia and we introduced ourselves. And how did that go? Do you know, it went absolutely brilliantly. We went to his office and we said, we're two young men. Did he speak English? Actually, I'm being very unfair because I'm leaving out Simon's girlfriend, who was also a president.
真的吗？当我们身处索菲亚时，我们自我介绍说。结果怎么样？你知道吗，结果绝对太棒了。我们去了他的办公室，我们说：“我们是两个年轻人——”他会说英语吗？事实上我很不公平，因为我漏掉了西蒙的女朋友，她也是一个在场者。
So there was actually three of us. But I mean, I don't think she had a great stake in meeting Boncho Todorov. He did speak a bit of English. Why did you have a great stake? Well, I'll explain. We've come all the way from England. And this will not surprise listeners at all. We said, we're from Oxford University in England
所以实际上我们有三个人。但我的意思是，我不认为她对会见邦乔·托多罗夫抱有很大热情。他确实会说一点英语。为什么你们会抱有很大热情？好吧，我来解释一下。我们一路从英格兰赶来。这绝对不会让听众感到意外。我们说：“我们来自英格兰的牛津大学，
and therefore very important. Could you give us free tickets for Bulgaria's crucial World Cup qualifier against Russia at the National Stadium tomorrow? And unbelievably, he said yes, and he did. Well, I suppose if you don't ask, you don't get, do you? Well, exactly. I mean, people talk about the entitlement of the Oxbridge educated. Was this just after the...
因此非常重要。你能给我们免费的门票，去看明天在国家体育场举行的保加利亚对阵俄罗斯的关键世界杯预选赛吗？”难以置信的是，他竟然说好，而且他真的给了。好吧，我想如果你不开口要求，你就什么也得不到，不是吗？完全正确。人们总是在谈论牛津毕业生的特权。这难道是在……
This is 1990s. So I suppose kind of visiting Oxford students was still a novelty at that point. I think a bit of a novelty, yes. I didn't then come back and dress as a Bulgarian. A Bulgarian. From the 1990s i mean that they were that was a very shell-suited aesthetic then if i could have done i could have done maybe a national team shell suit maybe who knows for our next rest is history club get together
这是1990年代。所以我想那时访问牛津的学生仍然是一件新鲜事。我想确实有点新鲜，是的。我当时并没有回来把自己打扮成一个保加利亚人。一个保加利亚人。从1990年代开始——我的意思是，那是一种非常尼龙运动服（shell-suit）的美学。如果我能的话，我可能会——可能穿一套国家队的尼龙运动服，谁知道呢？为了我们下一次的“历史的 rest”俱乐部聚会，
um which you of course can be present at dear listener if you join the rest is history club maybe i should wear a bulgarian shell suit And Tom, you can wear your Indian garb. Yeah, in national dress. There's nothing more boring than people talking about the holiday, so I think we should probably at this point... We could be doing that all week. And when we come back, let's have a look at what, while the Millords are going off on their foreign trips,
——亲爱的听众，如果你加入“历史的 rest”俱乐部，你当然也可以出席——也许我应该穿一套保加利亚的尼龙运动服。而汤姆，你可以穿你的印度服饰。对，穿民族服装。没有什么比人们谈论假期更无聊的了，所以我认为我们此刻可能应该……我们整个星期都可以谈论这个。当我们回来时，让我们看看，当贵族勋爵们进行他们的海外旅行时，
what is happening in Britain. Okay, jolly good. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
英国正在发生什么。好的，太好了。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的 rest》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝不苟的秀场八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和提前获取现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
If one could but go to Brighton. That is, as all readers of Jane Austen will recognise, is the exclamation given by both Lydia Bennett and her mother in Jane Austen's Pride and Prejudice. Dominic, we have moved on from the 18th century to the Regency period. And the Regency period, of course, is caterminous with the Napoleonic Wars. And the Napoleonic Wars make it difficult for Milords or indeed anyone else to go on travels across the continent. And so Britain's upper classes, upper middle classes have to gain a kind of vocational self-sufficiency. And Brighton obviously is one of those places. And I suppose the other one is another place beginning with B, Bath. So what's the story of how Bath and Brighton
如果能去一趟布赖顿就好了。正如简·奥i Austen所有读者所知，这是简·奥斯汀的小说《傲慢与偏见》中莉迪亚·贝内特和她母亲发出的感叹。多米尼克，我们已经从18世纪进入了摄政时期。而摄政时期，当然与拿破仑战争同时代。拿破仑战争使得贵族老爷们，或者实际上任何其他人，都很难去欧洲大陆旅行。因此，英国的上层阶级和中上层阶级不得不获得一种职业上的自给自足。布赖顿显然就是其中一个地方。我想另一个地方是以B开头的巴斯。那么，巴斯和布赖顿是如何演变成
become the kind of honey pots for Jane Austen style tourists? Well, I suppose you could say that Bath and Brighton are two of the world's first modern holiday destinations, couldn't you? So Bath is first, and they're both to do with doctors. That's really interesting. So the interweaving of health and holidays, the idea that you travel, you go on a break, you go for the, you know, now we think of as people will say, I need the sea air, you know, I need sunshine, I crave sunshine, you know, all that sort of stuff. It'll feel refreshed.
简·奥斯汀式游客的蜂巢的？嗯，我想你可以说巴斯和巴赖顿是世界上最早的两个现代度假胜地，不是吗？所以巴斯是第一个，而且它们都跟医生有关。这真的很有趣。因此，健康与假期的交织，那种你旅行、去度假、去追求你懂的，现在我们认为是人们会说，我需要海风，你知道，我需要阳光，我渴望阳光，所有这些类似的东西。感觉神清气爽。
I'll come back a new man or new woman. That goes back to the sort of late 17th, early 18th century. And one of the first people who really popularized this was a guy who was a doctor from Hampshire. He was of Italian descent, actually. His family were called Guidotti, but he called himself Thomas Guidott. And he moved to Bath in 1668. So he's a doctor. And he publishes a series of sort of investigations into the waters of
我会脱胎换骨地回来。这可以追溯到17世纪末18世纪初。最早真正普及这种做法的人之一，是一个来自汉普郡的医生。他实际上有意大利血统。他的家族叫吉多蒂，但他自称托马斯·吉多特。他在1668年搬到了巴斯。所以他是一名医生。他发表了一系列关于
bath because of course bath you know it's the name so it's a spa and it's been a spa since roman times so um he his book his most successful book is called a discourse of bath and the hot waters there also some inquiries into the nature of the water of St. Vincent's Rock near Bristol, published in 1676, and with its catchy title, proves a tremendous hit. Flying off the shelves. Yeah, absolutely. And so people are generally, I suppose, it's the age of politeness, of civility, of gentility. People are more interested in their health.
巴斯温泉水的调查研究。因为当然巴斯，你知道，这就是它的名字，所以它是一个温泉小镇，而且自罗马时代起就是一个温泉小镇，所以嗯，他的书，他最成功的一本书叫做《关于巴斯及当地温泉的论著》（A Discourse of Bath and the Hot Waters There），其中还包含一些对布里斯托尔附近圣文森特岩水质性质的探究，出版于1676年，凭借其抓人眼球的书名，取得了巨大的成功。卖得脱销。是的，完全如此。所以人们普遍地，我想，这是一个讲究礼貌、文明、绅士风度的时代。人们对自己的健康更加感兴趣。
You get all these sort of martyrs to their health in the 18th century so people and people are looking to escape you know booming expanding um sort of increasingly polluted indeed increasingly industrial london so they start going to bath bath is rebuilt in georgian style gets the the theater and he gets the pump room and so by the middle of the circus doesn't it gets the circus exactly do you know the circus was modeled on is it the it's been the subject of a podcast we've done quite recently golly stonehenge is it modeled on stonehenge yeah so the the the proportions are modeled on stonehenge and because the circus provides the model for the modern day British roundabout,
18世纪你会看到各种各样对健康着迷的殉道者，所以人们都在寻找逃离蓬勃发展、不断扩张的、某种程度上日益污染的、实际上日益工业化的伦敦的途径。所以他们开始去巴斯，巴斯以乔治亚风格重建，有了剧院，有了泵房，所以到了中期还有圆形广场，不是吗？它有了圆形广场，没错。你知道圆形广场是以什么为蓝本建造的吗？是那个吗？它最近刚刚成为我们做过的一个播客的主题，天哪，巨石阵吗？它是以巨石阵为蓝本建造的吗？是的。所以它的比例是以巨石阵为蓝本的，因为圆形广场为现代英国环岛提供了样板，
you could say that the roundabout too is an homage to Stonehenge. Anyway, I just throw that out. Very good. If listeners have enjoyed that, please direct your comments to Tom and not to me. So anyway, Tom, if you had gone to Bath on holiday in let's say the 1740s or 1750s,
你也可以说环岛同样是对巨石阵的一种致敬。不管怎样，我只是随口一提。很好。如果听众喜欢这个，请把你们的意见发给汤姆，而不是我。所以不管怎样，汤姆，如果你在比如说1740年代或1750年代去巴斯度假，
what would you have done first? What was your first thing I've done when you, when your coach, your stage coach arrived? I would have taken snuff. Well, what, but then what would you have done? I would bow to the, to the ladies. Not bad, but you should have gone to see Bonash. Of course, Bonash. Yes. Because Bonash is the most important person. Yeah have gone to see Bonash. Of course, Bonash, yes. Because Bonash is the most important person. Yeah, tell me about Bonash. Remind me about Bonash. So Bonash is this sort of self-appointed...
你第一件会做什么事？当你、当你乘坐的马车、你的驿马车到达时，你做的第一件事是什么？我会吸鼻烟。好吧，那，但之后你会做什么？我会向女士们鞠躬。还不错，但你本该去见博纳什的。当然，博纳什。是的。因为博纳什是最重要的人物。是的，跟我讲讲博纳什。提醒我一下博纳什是谁。所以博纳什是一个这种自封的……
I mean, we should say it's not bone ash, is it? So it's not like a kind of a burnt bone. It's Beau, B-E-A-U. It's Beau as in the French word, beautiful. I don't think he was christened Beau. I think that's just a sort of, he's a a dandy like bo brummel uh so he will meet you if you're a new arrival and he will decide whether you're you're suitable to join this sort of the smart set who are called the company and these are people who have kind of the bon temps
我的意思是，我们应该说明这不是“骨灰”（bone ash），对吧？所以它不像那种烧焦的骨头。它是“波”（Beau），拼写是B-E-A-U。它是法语里“美丽”那个词的“博”。我想他受洗时不叫博。我想这只是一种，他是一个像布鲁梅尔那样的花花公子，所以如果你是个新来的人，他会见你，他会决定你是否适合加入这个被称为“社团”的时髦圈子，这些人拥有美好的时光（le bon temps）
these exactly these are people who get to pre-book all the sort of tables and who get to um i think i would set you up with women to dance with the balls uh these are people who get to go and join the card tables and sort of go walking with the right people and all of these kinds of things and so bonashash is the sort of – he is the sort of the oyster. He is the social facilitator. He is the – you know, he sets people – he's the matchmaker. He sets people up. He brings people together. He's the pimp.
这些，没错，这些人可以预订所有种类的桌子，可以去，我想我会为你安排舞会的舞伴，这些人可以去打牌，和对的人一起散步，诸如此类。所以博纳什就是那种——他就像是核心人物。他是社交助推器。他是——你知道，他把人们——他是红娘。他把人们撮合在一起。他把人们聚在一起。他是个皮条客。
He's the pimp. Really what you're saying. It's a very harsh way of describing. Yeah. And so this is the sort of – yeah, so that's Bath. You know, you go there if you're basically um you've got to be pretty well off i would say you've got your aristocratic or your sort of very very sort of high end of the kind of rising middle classes because you wouldn't want to go otherwise and
他是个皮条客。你实际上是这个意思。这是对它非常严厉的描述。是的。所以这就是那种——是的，这就是巴斯。你知道，如果你去那里，基本上——你得相当富有才行，我想说，你得是贵族或者那种正在崛起的资产阶级中的极高层人士，否则你才不想去
be snubbed by boat by bone ash would you no you absolutely wouldn't be awful you get off you get out your coach and there's a lot of a mid to late 18th century stuff satirising Bath and saying it's actually awful. And all the people in it are actually, you know, just the most terrible people. And that, I mean, that is setting a trend that runs right the way through the history of tourism and holidays, isn't it?
被博纳什冷落呢，对吧？不，你绝对不会，那太糟糕了。你从马车上下来，有大量18世纪中后期的作品在讽刺巴斯，说它其实糟透了。里面所有人实际上都，你知道，简直是最糟糕的人。而且，我的意思是，这开创了一个贯穿旅游业和度假历史的趋势，不是吗？
Is that places that become very fashionable, immediately people turn against them. Everybody hates them. So there's a brilliant book by Tobias Smollett called The Expedition of Humphrey Klinker. And one of the characters in that is this really grumpy Welsh squire called Matthew Bramble. And it's an epistrary novel, so it's all letters. And he writes to one of his friends and he says, I'm not going to do a Welsh accent because my Welsh accent just turns into Indian. He says, you must know I find nothing but disappointment at Bath, which is so altered that I can scarcely believe it's the same place I frequented 30 years ago.
那就是变得非常时髦的地方，人们会立即转而反对它们。所有人都讨厌它们。所以托比亚斯·斯莫利特写过一本精彩的书叫《温弗里·克林克漫游记》（The Expedition of Humphrey Klinker）。其中的一个角色是一个脾气暴躁的威尔士乡绅，名叫马修·布兰伯。这是一部书信体小说，所以全都是信件。他写信给他的一个朋友说，我不会学威尔士口音，因为我的威尔士口音只会变成印度口音。他说，你得知道我在巴斯只找到了失望，这里已经面目全非，我几乎不敢相信它是我30年前经常光顾的同一个地方。
I believe you will not deny that this place, which nature and providence seem to have intended as a resource from distemper and disquiet, has become the very centre of racket and dissipation. A national hospital it may be, but one would imagine that none but lunatics are admitted. And truly, I will give you leave to call me so if I stay much longer at Bath. So, you know, we're able to say it's a bad place. Now, the other places you mentioned, it was Brighton.
我想你不会否认这个地方——大自然和天意似乎本打算把它作为抵御疾病和不安的避难所——却已经变成了喧嚣和放荡的中心。它或许可以算是一家国家医院，但人们会以为这里只收容疯子。真的，如果我在巴斯多待一会儿，你就叫我疯子好了。所以，你知道，我们能够说这是一个糟糕的地方。现在，你提到的另一个地方是布赖顿。
So Brighton, again, it's a doctor who sort of sets that up. So Brighton wasn't even called Brighton at the beginning of the 18th century. Do you know what it was called? Brighton's Helm or something, isn't it? Brigham's Helm or something like that. Bright Helmstone, which I think is a much better name. So there was a doctor, a local doctor called Richard Russell, and he wrote it. You thought that title was catchy. He wrote a dissertation called Der Tabbe Glandulari, in which he basically said it was about your lymphatic glands and about how seawater would sort them all out,
所以布赖顿，同样地，是一个医生促成了这一切。所以在18世纪初，布赖顿甚至不叫布赖顿。你知道它以前叫什么吗？是布赖顿海姆（Brighton's Helm）还是别的什么吧？布赖姆海姆（Brigham's Helm）之类的。布赖特海姆施托恩（Bright Helmstone），我认为这是一个好得多的名字。所以当时有一位医生，当地的一位医生叫理查德·拉塞尔，他写了。你以为那个书名很吸引人。他写了一篇题为《关于淋巴腺的论述》（De Tabe Glandulari）的论文，他在其中基本上提到，这与你的淋巴腺有关，以及海水将如何治愈它们，
drinking seawater and immersing yourself in seawater. Is this actually medically the case? No. Or is he just making it up? No, any listeners tempted to, please do not follow and do not then, especially American listeners, do not sue us because you have followed
饮用海水并将自己浸泡在海水中。这在医学上真的是这样吗？不是。还是他只是胡编乱造的？不是的，任何动心的听众，请千万不要效仿，尤其是美国的听众，千万不要因为你们听从了
seawater prescriptions. That would be a very, very bad idea. I want to distance myself from Dr. Russell. But they go there and they drink seawater. Yeah, loads of doctors. So there's a guy called John Aswitter. There's a guy called Anthony Relon. And they are pumping out pamphlets and books saying, come here, get in the sea, have a swim, drink a load of seawater.
海水处方而起诉我们。那会是一个非常非常糟糕的主意。我想与拉塞尔医生保持距离。但他们去那儿喝海水。是的，一大群医生。有个叫约翰·阿斯威特的人。有个叫安东尼·雷龙的人。他们在大肆散发小册子和书籍，说来这里吧，下海去，游个泳，喝大量海水。
You'll be as right as rain. Is that because they genuinely, I suppose they do believe it? Or is it because they've bought up a whole load of clinics and guest houses along the seafront well dr russell who was the originator of the seawater business he definitely he bought a plot of land in brighton and um he bought himself a he built um the biggest house in Brighton where he could put his patients and the garden opened onto the beach. And, of course, you know, I mean, who knows? I don't think we know enough about him to know whether this was him,
你就会安然无恙。这是因为他们真的，我想他们确实相信这一点？还是因为他们买下了海滨的一大堆诊所和客栈？嗯，拉塞尔医生，也就是海水生意的始作俑者，他绝对是，他在布赖顿买了一块地，而且嗯，他给自己买了一栋，在布赖顿建造了最大的房子，他可以在那里安置他的病人，花园直接通向海滩。而且，当然，你知道，我的意思是，谁知道呢？我觉得我们对他的了解还不足以知道这到底是不是他，
you know, sensibly capitalising on what he thought was best for people. I don't think it is a scam from the beginning, actually. But, I mean, to be fair to him. We're being too cynical. To be fair to him and all these other quacks. I mean, there is a case, isn't there, for saying that they are onto something. Because presumably before this period, people aren't going, you know, people are not seeing the seaside as anything attractive. It's kind of wild and dangerous and the haunt of smugglers and such like.
你知道，明智地利用了他认为对人们最好的东西。其实我觉得从一开始这并不是一场骗局。但是，我的意思是，平心而论。我们太愤世嫉俗了。平心而论，对秘方他和其他所有庸医来说。我的意思是，有一种观点认为，不是吗，他们确实发现了一些门道。因为据我推测在此之前，人们并不认为，人们并不觉得海滨有什么吸引人的地方。它有点荒凉、危险，还是走私犯之类的出没之地。
Right, exactly. And you wouldn't go anywhere near it. But in fact people do find the sea restorative i mean that's why people go to the region i mean if there's any listeners i mean no doubt there are a lot of listeners who have been chuckling as we have at the idea of drinking seawater and and all that stuff but i mean how many of our listeners enjoy wild swimming or think that going for a really bracing walk on the beach you know well it'll blow the cobwebs away i mean i say that to you know whenever we go bracing walk on the beach you know will it'll blow the cobwebs away
对，没准儿。而且你根本不会靠近它。但事实上人们确实觉得大海有恢复精力的作用——我的意思是这就是为什么人们去这个地区——我的意思是如果有任何听众——毫无疑问有很多听众和我们一样，对喝海水以及所有这些东西的想法嗤之以鼻，但我的意思是，我们的听众中有多少人喜欢野外游泳，或者觉得去海滩进行一次真正令人振奋的散步，你知道，嗯，这会吹走烦恼——我的意思是每当我们去海滩散步时我都会对……说，我妻子甚至在我说出口之前就开始用恶狠狠的眼神瞪着我，她说你每次去散步时总是这么说。我真的能想象你穿着脏兮兮的假发、拿着手杖和大礼服，迈着大步走在卵石海滩上的样子，绝对是在冲着那些花花公子挥舞着手杖。我会喝一大堆咸水吗？我的意思是，我只是觉得我会吐出来——嗯，无论如何，这把布赖顿变成了一个——这个伟大的目的地，人们去那里饮用海水并下海。现在，事情是这样的。拉塞尔医生，也就是你指控为骗子的那个人，他在1759年去世了。
i mean i say that to you know whenever we go for a walk on the beach and just one of my my wife gets kind of glaring at me even before i say it she says you always say that when we go for a walk i can really imagine you stamping along a kind of shingle beach with your your dirty wig and a staff and a frock coat absolutely shaking your stick at macaronis would i drink a load of salty water i mean i just think i wouldn't be able to be sick um well anyway this this turns brighton into this um into this great sort of great destination people go there to take to sort of drink sea water and get in the get in the sea now here thing. Dr. Russell, the guy who you've accused of being a scam artist, he dies in 1759.
他的巨大宅邸……他喝了太多的海水。大概是的。盐中毒。他的巨大宅邸……到他死的时候，他完全是由盐组成的。罗得的妻子。
And his huge house... He's drinking too much seawater. Presumably. Salt poisoning. His huge house... He's made entirely of salt by the time of his death. Lot's wife.
是的，他们剖开他，里面只有海藻。不管怎样，听着。他的房子被出租给大人物——因为这是最大的房子，你知道是谁租了他的房子吗？摄政王，坎伯兰公爵，苏格兰的朋友。噢，屠夫，卡洛登的胜利者。
Yeah, they open him up and there's just seaweed Inside anyway listen His house is let to big Because it's the biggest house and do you know who rents His house Prince Regent The Duke of Cumberland friend of Scotland Oh Butcher Victor of Culloden
所以坎伯兰公爵继承了他的房子，而未来的乔治四世前去拜访坎伯兰公爵，因为坎伯兰公爵非常喜欢酗酒、快节奏的生活，并且喜欢打牌和赌博，未来的摄政王也是如此。于是未来的乔治四世在那里对布赖顿产生了绝对的兴趣，后来当他卷入其中时，他因为花钱太多等等而受到了训斥。这大约是三四年后。我不知道是政府还是他的父亲，
So the Duke of Cumberland Inherits his house And the future George IV Goes to visit the Duke of Cumberland because the Duke of Cumberland is very kind of hard drinking fast living and enjoys playing cards and gambling as does the future Prince Regent so there the future George IV gets this absolute taste for Brighton later on when he gets in he's he's been told off for spending too much money and so on. This is about three or four years later. And I don't know if it's the government or his father
或是其他什么人曾说过，你在伦敦过着这种放荡的生活。而他说，哦，不，不，不。我会改过自新。我是个新男人。我要在乡下租一座农舍。于是他在布赖顿租了一座农舍，就在布赖顿旁边，这样他就可以……他在布赖顿旁边租了一座农舍，这样他就可以继续他在布赖顿的旧生活。这一次，他为他的情妇在那里建立了一个宅邸，他显然在后来——委托人在布赖顿建造了皇家穹顶宫，皇家穹顶宫对于那些没看过或没听说过的人来说，是的，这是——它有点像是印度幻想风，对吧，带有圆顶和圆穹顶以及各种各样的东西，一种由幻想，对印度的幻想所变幻出来的东西——这是拉斯维加斯和迪士尼世界以及这种理念的某种原型吗？这是一个很好的
or whoever has said, you're living this dissipated life in London. And he says, oh, no, no, no. I'll turn over a new leaf. I'm a new man. I will rent a farmhouse in the country. And he rents a farmhouse in Brighton, next to Brighton, so that he can just he rents a farmhouse in brighton next to brighton so that he can just crack on with his old life in brighton this time he sets up an establishment for um his mistress there he obviously later on uh commissions the royal pavilion in brighton the the royal pavilion for those who haven't seen it or heard of it yeah is this um it's it's kind of indian fantasy isn't it with domes and cupolas and all kinds of things a kind of fantasy conjured up from you know fantasy of india is that the kind of prototype for las vegas and disney world and the idea of that's a good
比较。非凡的建筑，使一个目的地本身就能成为一个旅游目的地。是的，我想，是的，我认为这是一个非常好的比较。我之前没想到拉斯维加斯这个比较。但我的意思是，这正是人们在拉斯维加斯建造复制品时所做的事情。而且这一切都与赌博有关，不是吗，布赖顿也是如此？这全都是关于赌博。但回到这一集的上半部分，当人们在建造他们的乡间别墅，建造模仿罗马神庙的建筑等等时。我的意思是，这跟拉斯维加斯有什么区别？并不是说——好吧，他们没有赌博——尽管他们可能在私下赌博——但布赖顿确实有批评者。
comparison extraordinary buildings that that enable a destination to kind of in its own right become a tourist destination yeah i think yeah i think that's a really good comparison. Extraordinary buildings that enable a destination to kind of, in its own right, become a tourist destination. Yeah, I think that's a really good comparison, actually. It hadn't occurred to me, the Las Vegas comparison. But I mean, that's exactly what people do in Las Vegas when they build reproductions. And it's all about gambling, isn't it, as well, Brighton? It is all about gambling. But going back to the first half of this episode, when people are building their country houses and they're building imitation Roman temples and things. I mean, how different is that from las vegas not that i mean okay they're not gambling although they they may be gambling privately um but so brighton does have critics
所以最著名的批评者是简·奥斯汀。每个人都以为简·奥斯汀讨厌布赖顿，但实际上她并没有。所以你引用了《傲慢与偏见》，但她确实去过——我的意思是她去游泳了，她——她使用了一种沐浴车。人们有沐浴车，因为显然人们还没学会游泳，所以这种车有台阶，由一头驴拉着进入海中，并且——所以有一个专门从事这项工作的人被称为“浸入员”（dipper），浸入员会帮你进去，把你的身体浸入水中，这就是简·奥斯汀经历的事情。我的意思是，那是20年前还不存在的工作，我猜？不，完全没有。是的，我的意思是——这就是旅游业提供就业机会的一个例子。
so the most famous critic is jane austen everyone thinks that jane austen hated brighton but actually she didn't so you quoted pride and prejudice um but she did go i mean she went swimming she um she went she used a sort of bathing machine people had bathing machines because obviously people hadn't learned to swim so the machine had sort of had steps and it was pulled by a donkey into the sea and um so there was there was somebody who worked on it called a dipper and the dipper would help you in sort of lower you into the water and this is what happened to jane austen i mean that's a job that didn't exist 20 years before i assume no not at all yeah i mean so that's an example of tourism providing employment
是的，绝对的。嗯，我现在会雇佣一个浸入员，如果——我喜欢游泳，但有个人帮我浸入水中会给我带来极大的满足感。不管怎样，汤姆，我想你手里还有个摄政时期的浪子，就像你之前袖子里藏着波斯威尔一样，我想你手里还藏着另一个浪子。好吧，我有拜伦。我们从拜伦开始。所以敏锐的听众会注意到，我提到了拜伦是如何在1809年踏上他的游历之旅的。
yeah absolutely um i would hire a dipper now if i mean i like swimming but it would give me enormous satisfaction to have a dipper anyway tom i think you have a regency you just as you had boswell up your sleeve, I think you have another rake up your sleeve. Well, I've got Byron. We began with Byron. So alert listeners will have noticed that I mentioned how Byron went off on his tour in 1809.
他们大概也会敏锐地注意到滑铁卢战役是在1815年。那么拜伦要去哪里呢？好吧，他和他的朋友约翰·卡姆·霍布豪斯（John Cam Hobhouse）一起去，还有他们极其英国化的贴身男仆威廉·弗莱彻（William Fletcher），他绝对是身在异国他乡的英国人的化身，对食物心存怀疑，一句当地语言都不会说，诸如此类。
And they will be alert presumably as well to the fact that Battle of Waterloo is in 1815. So where was Byron going? Well, he goes with his friend, John Cam Hobhouse, and their unbelievably British valet, William Fletcher, who is absolutely the embodiment of the Englishman abroad, suspicious of the food, doesn't speak a word of the language, all that kind of stuff.
所以他们去了对英国贵族老爷们开放的地方，即葡萄牙、马耳他。然后他们有点像——有点像波斯威尔去科西嘉岛的山区那样，他们去了阿尔巴尼亚，他们遇到了一个叫阿里帕夏（Ali Pasha）的人，这是一个非常迷人的人物。他据说是君士坦丁堡苏丹的臣民，但事实上，他非常自主地经营着自己的事务。他非常喜欢那种奇异的面部毛发、华丽的服饰。事实上，阿里帕夏和他的阿尔巴尼亚亲信穿的那种华丽服饰，拜伦也弄到了一套。所以就像波斯威尔曾弄到一套科西嘉服装一样，拜伦也弄到了一套阿尔巴尼亚服饰。
So they go to places that are open to British millords, namely Portugal, Malta. And then they kind of follow, you know, rather a bit like Boswell going to the mountainous reaches of Corsica, they go to Albania and they meet this guy called Ali Pasha, who is a very glamorous figure. He's supposedly subject to the Sultan in Constantinople, but in fact, he's very much set up on his own business. He's a great one for the kind of exotic facial hair, flamboyant costumes. And in fact, these kind of flamboyant costumes that Ali Pasha and his Albanian henchmen are wearing, Byron gets one. So exactly as Boswell had got a Corsican outfit, Byron gets an Albanian outfit.
当他回来时，他让人画了一幅自己穿着这套服装的画像。在某种程度上，这成了绝对的原型，我认为，这就是出国旅游的游客、背包客、Gap Year（间隔年）的人，出国旅游，带回一套荒谬的服装，并穿上它。只是拜伦可能第一个这么做，而且绝对是最时髦的一个。所以他总是能驾驭它。不管怎样，从阿尔巴尼亚出发，拜伦前往希腊，希腊当然仍处于奥斯曼帝国的统治之下，非常非常偏远。尽管它绝对是——你知道，浪漫主义想象的一部分，拜伦在学校里学过希腊语。
And when he comes back, he has himself painted wearing it. And in a way, this becomes the absolute archetype, I think, of the tourist going abroad, the backpacker, the guy on the gap year, whatever, going abroad, coming back with a ludicrous costume, wearing it. It's just that Byron was probably the first to do it and certainly the most stylish. And so he's always got away with it. Anyway, so from Albania, Byron goes on to Greece, which of course is still under the Ottoman Empire, is very, very remote. Although it absolutely part of the, you know, the romantic imagination Byron has studied Greek at school.
帕台农神庙的影像以及所有类似的东西绝对在他的脑海中，但它是非常非常野性的。然后他去了君士坦丁堡。他回来后，把这些写成了一部令人难以置信的——你知道，作为浪漫主义诗歌的原型。拜伦描绘了阿尔巴尼亚山区的强盗。他描绘了帕台农神庙。雅典只是一个小小的、杂草丛生的村庄。他描绘了君士坦丁堡的辉煌，对于一个渴望旅行的英国
It's images of the Parthenon and all that kind of stuff is absolutely in his, his mind's eye, but it's very, very wild. And he goes on to Constantinople. He comes back and he writes this up as an unbelievable, you know as the archetype of the romantic poem. And Byron is describing bandits in the hills of Albania. He's describing the Parthenon. Athens is just a scrubby little village. He's describing the glories of of constantinople and for a a travel starved british
公众来说，这简直是炸药，你知道，这就像是吸毒后的迈克尔·帕林（Michael Palin）对他们而言，他们变得痴迷，它成为了英国出版史上——英国出版史上最畅销的诗歌，真的，遥遥领先，绝对遥遥领先，而拜伦也成了一位超级巨星。他醒来——你知道，“我醒来发现自己成名了”，他有一句名言。是的。但在1816年，他遇到了一些个人问题，也就是他一直在与自己的同父异母姐姐乱伦。这引发了一场巨大的丑闻。拜伦再次出国。
public this is dynamite you know this is michael palin on acid for them they they become obsessed and it becomes the best-selling poem ever in english publishing british publishing really by miles by absolute miles and byron becomes a superstar. He wakes up, you know, I woke up and found myself famous, he famously said. Yeah. But then in 1816, he has certain personal problems, namely that he has been committing adultery with his own half-sister. And this generates a great scandal. Byron goes abroad again.
当他启程横渡海峡时——现在，当然，他可以去法国了，因为滑铁卢战役已经打响。他又一次将这一切永垂青史在《恰尔德·哈洛尔德游记》（Childe Harold's Pilgrimage）中。于是他写了《恰尔德·哈洛尔德》的另一首长诗（canto）：因为我是一株被抛掷在巨浪泡沫中的岩石上的野草，任凭巨浪横扫，暴风雨的气息肆虐。他继续前行，沿着莱茵河来到瑞士、意大利、威尼斯、佛罗伦萨、罗马。但当然，他现在所做的事情要常规得多，因为他走的是壮游（Grand Tour）路线。尽管他仍然把自己塑造成一个厄运缠身、孤独、浪漫的人物，但事实是，他只是把贵族老爷们在整个18世纪一直在做的事情变成了诗歌形式。但还有一个额外的复杂情况，它使得拜伦旅行的现实情况以及《恰尔德·哈洛尔德》第三和第四首长诗的背景变得几乎有些可悲，那就是到目前为止，出国旅行已经不仅仅是贵族老爷们的专利了。所以可能最著名的是
And as he sets off across the channel, and now, of course, he can go to France because the Battle of Waterloo has been fought. He again will immortalize this in Childe Harold. So he writes another canto of Childe Harold. for I am as a weed flung from the rock on oceans foam to sail where air the surge may sweep the tempest's breath prevail and on he goes through down the Rhine to Switzerland to Italy to Venice Florence Rome but of course what he's doing now is much more conventional because he's taking the route of the grand tour. And although he is kind of casting himself still as this doomed, lonely, romantic figure, the truth is that actually he's just putting into poetic form everything that the mid-lords have been doing through the 18th century. But there is an added complication that makes the reality of Byron's trip and provides a kind of context for Childe Harold, these third and fourth cantos of Childe Harold, that's almost pathetic, which is that by now, going abroad is not just for millords. So possibly the most famous
《恰尔德·哈洛尔德》中的那段话，拜伦去了滑铁卢——你知道，这个头骨之地，他称之为法国的坟墓——他想象了里士满公爵夫人（Duchess of Richmond）在滑铁卢前夜举办的著名舞会：夜色中曾有狂欢的声音，比利时的首都那时聚集了她的美丽与骑士精神，明亮的灯光照耀着美丽的女性和勇敢的男子。但到了这个时候，不仅是拜伦一个人去滑铁卢并写下那种——你知道的，优美诗歌的人，你基本上会遇到各种各样的人——厂主、富有的律师、各种拜伦唯恐避之不及的社会渣滓。而多米尼克，我认为这正在开创一个新时代，不是吗？这是一个将成为
passage in Childe Harold is where byron goes to waterloo you know this place of skulls the grave of france he calls it and he imagines the famous ball held by the duchess of richmond on the eve of waterloo there was a sound of revelry by night and belgium's capital had gathered then her beauty and her chivalry and bright the lamps shone over fair women and brave men but by this point it's not just byron who is going to waterloo and writing kind of you know beautiful poetry like that you are getting basically all kinds of people mill owners uh prosperous lawyers all kinds of riffraff that byron wouldn't be seen dead with. And that, Dominic, I think is ushering in a new age, isn't it? It's an age of what will become
某种大众旅游的时代。同样，我们讨论了英国人如何通过布赖顿和巴斯发明了那么多东西，我猜这是一个延续到现代、现代旅游业的连续体。但我也有一种感觉，我认为在滑铁卢之后，从摄政时期到维多利亚时期的过渡中，英国人还发明了许多我们会与现代旅游业联系在一起的东西。所以我想我们下次应该探讨一下这个，不是吗？我们应该继续这个话题。我们应该为此做一整个系列，因为像往常一样，我们绝对应该这么做。我们，
kind of a mass tourism. And again, we talked about how the British invent with Brighton and with Bath so much that is, I suppose, a continuum running into the modern day, the modern tourist industry. But there's also a sense, I think, in which post-Waterloo, the Regency period going into the Victorian period, the British are also inventing so much that we would associate with the modern tourism industry. And so I think we should look at that next time, shouldn't we? We should continue this. We should make an entire series of it because as usual, we absolutely should. We have,
我想确实如此。我想下次我们将探讨——大众旅游的到来。所以——托马斯·库克（Thomas Cook）的阴影、库克的旅行团、铁路、轮船、度假胜地——不仅在英国，不仅仅是海滨度假胜地，还有德国、美国。然后我们将从那里最终进入20世纪，谁知道还有以后。所以我们下次见。
I think exactly that. I think next time we will look at, um, the advent of mass tourism. So the, the shadow of Thomas Cook and Cook's tours of, of railways of steamships, um,
再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家加更节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
of resorts, not just in, um, in Britain, not seaside resorts, but in Germany, in the United States. And then we will go on from that eventually into the 20th century and who knows beyond. So we'll see you then.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝演艺界八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Goodbye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
再见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听加长节目、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点八分八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加长节目和抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。